تعذبنا في طول المده بس مجرد تعذييب يعني
حتى بسالش بس بده هجوم عنيف بشكل مش طبيعي
يعني انا الدم بينزل من راسي وبقول له
الدم بخبط بزياده بزيد اذا توجعت بزيد اذا
حكيت بزيد الضرب ضرب مش طبيعي مش
طبيعي
الارض كلها حصمه وحاطين عليها حرامات
وكلها مي ققول لك نام عليها ظلينا نايمين
يومين
واحنا اربعه ايام لا اكل ولا شرب ولا اي
حاجه يقول له بس بدي نقطه مي اشربها
بالريق يمسك قزاز المي يديرها قدامي هيك
ققول لي
مي اخذوني خلوني معهم اكسر ابواب واكسر
حطان وبعدين ربطوني فداي وخلوني منزل
رقبتي وفي المواسير يخبطوا في وفي الكريك
وفي السلاح ا ا وعدين خذ رموه ب مربطين
ويوم في السقع على البحر ويوم في الهلال
وبعدين رجعونا بعرفش وين شكله طلعونا على
ايرز او على منطقه بعيده الدبابه قعدت في
ساعه
تمشي ورموه في مكان هناك زي
البركس ه ايدي من
الكلبشه ورجلي اطلع كيف
رجلي كله كله ضرب ورجليه من تحت كلبشات
كمان ومن رجلي من هنا كمان شوف اطلع
كيف شايف وين الكلبشات شايف كيف هي كلبشات
اطلع كيف رجليه
من الكلبشات
كلها وهذا حالنا يعني
ليش بتعرفش طب احنا طالعين مدنيين احنا
بقول يا عم احنا طالعين مسالمين حنا احنا
مدنيين وعريانين يعني لا عننا سلاح ولا
عننا
حاجه وليش المعامله
هذه